A well written ReadMe is one of the most
important parts of a good repository.
The reading is necessary for
others because it tells people
what the code is for, how to build an
installer code, and how to contribute.
To teach you how to write a good ReadMe,
I'm going to hand you
off to my friend Walter.
>> Hey!
>> Hey.
Nice to see you.
>> Well, sure thanks for having me.
>> Thanks for coming.
So I have some students who need
to learn how to write ReadMe.
>> Well, that's perfect because
I teach a course on just that.
It's less than an hour long.
And it will teach you everything
you know about writing documentation for
humans.
>> Thanks.
So you'll find a link to Walter's
lesson in the instructor notes.
When you're finished with it,
head back here and will continue.